place de l'indépendance portable et
lampe torche allumée en guise de lueur
d'espoir depuis plus de 70 jours des
dizaines de milliers de manifestants
sont descendus dans les rues pour
interpeller leur principal bouc
émissaire monsieur borisov souvenez vous
de cela la roue de l'histoire est en
mouvement
gardez les yeux ouverts pour ne pas
passer dessous de nuit comme de jour
ils réclament le départ du premier
ministre boïko borissov
ce dernier a été élu en 2009 en 2014 et
à nouveau en 2017
après avoir démissionné deux fois en
trois ans une présence devenue
embarrassante irritante pour une grande
majorité des bulgares une crise
économique nous frappe non seulement en
bulgarie mais aussi dans le monde entier
et nous avons un gouvernement qui s'est
révélé incompétents et corrompus et dont
on ne peut attendre qu'il soit à la
hauteur face à la crise qui s'annonce
je pense donc que les gens ne veulent
plus vivre dans un pays corrompu et
qu'ils souhaitent un état de droit
les objectifs sont clairs mettre un
terme à la corruption la démission du
procureur général
c'est ce dont nous avons désespérément
besoin des manifestations déclenchées
début juillet notamment après des
perquisitions menées au siège du
président roumaine radev qui accusent le
premier ministre d'être derrière cette
manoeuvre
le chef de l'état aux fonctions limitées
et proche de l'opposition socialiste
demande également la démission du
gouvernement et appelle à des élections
anticipées
de son côté boïko borissov en poste
jusqu'en mars 2021 semble vouloir gagner
du temps car j'ai je vais poursuivre les
discussions avec mes partenaires de
coalition et je vais proposer des
options y compris celle de partir et de
laisser le gouvernement au pouvoir
il a plongé promet des discussions et
une proposition de réforme
constitutionnelle qui ne passe pas avec
des pouvoirs importants toujours accordé
au procureur général visé par les
protestataires
manifestants et forces de l'ordre se
sont opposés début septembre devant le
parlement bulgare avec des dizaines de
blessés
pour rappel selon les ong transparency
international la bulgarie où demeure le
pays le plus pauvre et le plus corrompu
de l'union européenne